كعادته في كل ظهور او تصريح لا يكف
الملياردير الامريكي الماسك ملكه تويتر
الجديد عن اثاره الجدل فبعد عمليه
استحواذه على منصه تويتر التي اثارت جدلا
عالميا واسعا وتضمن التسريح الاف الموظفين
وفرض رسوم على الحسابات الموثقه يعود ماسك
ليظهر خلال قمه مجموعه العشرين مخاطبا
رجال اعمال مدينه بالي في اندونيسيا من
خلال رابط الفيديو وهو يجلس في الظلام
مرتديا قميصا اندونيسيا تقليديا ومحاطا
بالشموع ولا يظهر منه سوى وجهه ويديه حيث
قدم الى الماسك رؤيته للمستقبل التي لا
تقل غرابه و جراه شملت كائنات فضائيه
وانفاقا عميقه ورحلات سياحيه بالصواريخ في
اقل من ساعه
على المدى الطويل سيكون من المنطقي جدا
تشين منساط اطلاق صواريخ في جميع انحاء
العالم اعتقد ان لدينا بالفعل ظروفا بوفيه
تمكننا من السفر بالصواريخ من منطقه الى
اخرى حول العالم
المزيد من سياره تسلا الكهربائيه باسعار
معقوله واعرب من خلالها عن تفائله بمستقبل
اندونيسيا كدوله الناميه لم تقف فيها
غرابه الحديث عند هذا الحد فيبدو ان الهن
يحلم بخلق عالم اقل ازدحاما ليس بالسيارات
الطائره بل من خلال انفاق عميقه تحت الارض
لكنه ورغم احلامه الجريئه حول المستقبل
فان اغنى اثرياء العالم الذي كان محاطا
بالشموع خلال حديث بسبب انقطاع في التيار
الكهربائي لم يتردد في التعبير عن اهميه
ايجاد اي ابتكار يسهل حياه البشر حتى وان
تطلب الامر اكتشاف الحياه خارج الكره
الارضيه رنده الشيخ العربي